wow getting this one up early thanks
embargo before we get started of course
i'm gonna thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
batman that would be the original audio
series batman unburied streaming
exclusively on spotify batman unburied
is a news story it's not adapted from
any previously existing works other than
the voice acting which i thought was
great in here i love the superb use of
audio and sound effects to paint the
grim tone of gotham that was
fantastically done and from there you
have a very captivating and engrossing
thriller slash mystery involving the
heroes villains and otherwise characters
of gotham it starts off you're confused
but in all the right ways we're like
what's going on so batman unburied is
free to listen to on spotify it's only
available on spotify don't forget to
vote in the poll in the description of
this video thank you once again to
batman for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it
i don't even care i'm thanking batman
no one can make me not and now buckle in
because i got the need the need for
speed
oh i like this look i might keep it i
might never go back so top gun maverick
is the sequel to 1986's top gun in top
gun maverick there's this impossible run
that pilots at top gun need to be
trained to do to do that you not only
need a top gun but you need
a maverick of all the pilots out there
to train these new pilots to do this run
why get the one who came in runner up in
1986 because tom cruise and shut up
there is a story based reason for it but
the point is maverick is back this time
as an instructor at top gun i'll get to
my favorite part of this movie last i'm
going to save the best for last best for
me anyway and turns out this movie is
way better than it had any right to be
first of all tom cruise is still on
cruise control dude still got it i hope
i look that good when i'm that old it's
coming up sooner than later but i love
seeing maverick as an instructor it's
one of the cool things about this movie
it's also one of the things that makes
another element in this movie fall short
because it's maverick as the instructor
you know you're behind maverick you're
rooting for maverick which is what we
were doing in the original top gun but
we were rooting for maverick and goose
as students they go up against jester
and you're like oh yeah take jester out
now maverick is the jester for these new
recruits so you're rooting for the
instructor to take out the recruits
you're not really rooting for the
underdogs in this movie which i'm fine
with because we all root for tom cruise
i guess i mean he has a bat [ __ ] weird
religion that he's a part of but you
know we still root for him in movies
having him as the instructor and it
wasn't in the original trailer but it
was in the second trailer the reveal of
course like we already knew though like
who does miles teller play just look at
his face whose son is he
right looks just like him but having
maverick as the instructor and goose's
son as one of the recruits there was a
a strong family dynamic in this movie
that i just didn't expect well that said
if we're comparing this to the original
top gun the recruits in the original top
gun i felt like it was it was easier to
see the synergy among the students you
know he had iceman and his crew and that
was clearly that click you know and you
had goose and maverick and they were
clearly over here in a different click
it had that high school cafeteria
element to it which doesn't end after
high school sorry for some of you who
might be really excited you know maybe
you're graduating this year maybe you're
graduating in a month you're like yeah i
don't have to put up with this high
school [ __ ] you do it doesn't end at
graduation folks i'm sorry to say but
the recruits in this movie i didn't feel
that they were just like a conglomerate
of people who were good pilots because
you're told they're great pilots it's
like they just vomited new recruits in
this movie that we're supposed to care
about more than i actually did care
about there's support characters that
didn't stand out so much that said
maverick being the star did and his
dynamic with miles teller who plays
goose's son and actually i do prefer
that as opposed to the alternative the
alternative is it's a top gun movie
where it revolves around these new
recruits you don't really care about and
tom cruise is some support character
who's the instructor but doesn't revolve
around him you know just sounds like a
worse movie so if you see it as choice
number one choice number two i like the
choice they made revolving it around tom
cruise who is the instructor however i
think there is a third option where
everybody flows more smoothly and the
recruits actually stand out and have a
dynamic that's more solid than this
movie had a thing i did not dig much at
all in this movie is there's this love
interest with jennifer connelly i mean i
love jennifer connelly who doesn't she's
a goddess among us mortals absolutely if
you can have jennifer connelly in your
movie go for it but it sounds like
that's how she was cast where they were
like whoa we can have jennifer connolly
in this movie
we don't have a spot for her in the
script all right we'll make one up so
she says will they won't they kind of
love interest for tom cruise's character
and it's just kind of if you took that
entire love interest arc and just wiped
it out just took it out of this movie
the fundamental film at its core
wouldn't really change at all i can't
help but feel like they had her in this
movie because it's it's the fundamentals
are going for this is a sequel to a
movie from 1986 what would 1986 movies
have you know what the movies in the 80s
what are they known for kick-ass action
shirtless volleyball scene montages and
love interests but yeah i didn't care
but i also appreciate the fact that
though this movie does have its
its throwbacks you know its love letters
to the original top gun i thought of
that because i just said shirtless
volleyball montage no there is no
shirtless volleyball montage in this one
there is however a shirtless beach
football scene so you know rolling with
the times but still love letter
nonetheless and the intro of this movie
i didn't even talk about that like the
intro to this movie it does a good job
at doing what it needs to do to remind
you hey top gun sequel without a title
if you watch the intro to top gun
maverick anyone would be forgiven for
thinking this is actually the intro to
the original top gun that they're
watching that said i felt top gun
maverick did it better than a lot of
other movies that use nostalgia bait
whereas this movie kind of just cuts it
off they're like okay the energy's there
we got the audience massaged in and now
we're gonna do the sequel thing this
movie had a good balance of you know
it's like yeah that's nostalgia but also
we're pushing the story forward but the
coolest thing about top gun maverick for
me man i don't even care it was the
aviation the dog fights the training
cause when i watch the trailer maybe
it's because it's on a smaller screen
you don't really think about it when you
see the trailer but when i was in the
movie theater i was like wait are they
actually in jets filming in the air it
felt like you are in the cockpit like
the actors are in the cockpit and
they're dog fighting there's a small
little making of youtube video
featurette out there and it shows them
in the cockpit in the air and they're
talking about how important it was to
actually film this live it was awesome
to see that little featurette also
wasn't surprising after watching the
movie because you feel how real it is in
a world where we've seen enough movies
out there you know that have jets and or
dogfights and they were made recently
and you know someone's in a cockpit and
they cgi everything in it just it feels
sterile and safe top gun maverick i felt
like i was in a jet in the air it feels
so much more visceral so much faster so
much more dangerous because they're
blasting through the air i just i loved
that about this movie for nothing else
man when this blu-ray comes out or 4k
when it comes out on video i am praying
praying for hours upon hours of special
features making of i want to see how
they filmed this movie this movie had a
surprising amount of heart i need to say
that in this video damn dude like when i
say i was almost brought to tears in a
scene
i mean it and for me this one's worth
buying on blu-ray when it comes out all
right so top gun maverick have you seen
it what did you think about it reviews a
little early so in that case are you
looking forward to it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you